okay so the governor of the bank of
england called cryptocurrencies
dangerous and he said that he's
skeptical about it but
there's actually nothing more dangerous
than your very own
money losing value so let's take a look
at the pound so
this graph if i move myself out the way
shows you the purchasing power between
1860 to 2021 on the right-hand side and
house declined over the last 161 years
so one pound back in 1860 is actually
the equivalent
to 124 pounds in 2021.
this is actually an average inflation
rate of 3.04
over the last 161 years this means that
one pound today could only get you 0.8
percent of what it could have got in you
only 161 years ago it's really not that
long ago
so i gotta say i'm a lot more skeptical
about the purchasing power of the pound
and this devaluation looks far more
dangerous